hi everyone um just before I get started
um has anyone ever used processing
before like show of hands okay close
some people have that's awesome so I'm
not talking to people who are like
totally strangers to it so I'm so
excited to be here honestly like I have
literally been hearing about Cascadia
j/s for years so it's really cool to be
here and actually be presenting for you
guys on a topic but I really like uh and
I wanted to just take a moment to
acknowledge all of the organizers who've
put in so much work to organize this
like it's really not easy so if we could
just give a little round of applause for
them thank you so much so um my name is
elgu sky and apparently I have one
jacket and I included a photo of me so
that you would know that in fact I am
NOT an imposter how do I look relatively
similar I think I do
um and today I'm so excited to be
talking to you guys about creative code
in the browser but before I get started
I just want to give you a little bit of
a roadmap of what you can expect over
the next 20 or so minutes so first of
all hello I'm gonna tell you a little
bit more about me and some of the work
that I do and how I use creative coding
in my process next I'm going to try my
very best to explain creative coding to
you or define it rather and I'm gonna
try to get you guys excited about
potentially using creative coding in
your own projects in the future next I'm
gonna talk to you guys about p5.js which
is a JavaScript library that makes it
really easy to do creative coding in the
browser and I'm gonna tell you a little
bit more about why I like it and finally
I'm gonna try to do a live demo of some
coding to see like actually the
nitty-gritty of how you get started you
will be impressed by how easy it is to
make cool stuff so who remembers this
this little guy not the pineapple but
rather mspaint I'm not sure about you
guys but I spent a lot of time with this
program when I was a kid probably
because the internet wasn't like
actually available at my house so even
though I knew that wasn't gonna be the
world's first millionaire from selling
my bitmap images I think it was like BMP
it's
um I still spend a lot of time working
on it and as I was doing that I was
learning new skills so I was learning
how to do things because kids and adults
we learned through exploration and play
and so while I was making these creative
things I was also learning how to use a
mouse I was learning how to work with
color etc etc and I can't help but think
that maybe I'm here today in part at
least and maybe for you guys too because
I had access to creative tech tools when
I was a kid but let me just improve my
skills so um
flash board a couple years actually many
years I grew up and I started working in
the arts and I actually came to coding
because when I was working in the arts I
wanted to develop media arts projects so
I started doing a little bit of stuff
with like max/msp and I was hooked I
really liked it and so I decided to take
a web development bootcamp I worked in
industry for a little while and then
decided that I was not done with school
yet so when I got an opportunity to go
back to school to do my masters of
Science and interactive arts and
technology at Simon Fraser University I
jumped at the chance because it meant
that I was going to be able to bring
together sort of my to like main things
that get me excited in life art and
technology and sort of combine them into
one so my main research area is actually
on child computer interaction so that's
one of the reasons I mentioned mspaint
earlier but I also research tangible
computing and so what tangible computing
means is manipulating digital
information with physical objects but
one thing I'm really fortunate about are
really thankful is that I actually get a
lot of time to be doing creative
projects when I'm at school so in my off
time I do a lot of like sort of like
self-improvement projects by just like
building weird things and I also get an
opportunity to work with a lot of
undergraduates and graduate students
who've never ever coded before and I get
to introduce them to it so before I
tried to define creative coding for you
I want to show you some of these
projects that I've worked on recently
but I think I would define as being
creative code so this is plant agachi it
is a smart planter I guess is what you'd
call it and it's like a
between at a Medina planter and so
basically when you're about to kill your
plant because you haven't watered him in
a couple weeks
he preemptively turns his eyes to exes
and then you're like oh I should take
care of that this is a brain computer
interface series of lights because you
know everyone sort of always wanted to
power a computer like a light with their
brain so it uses EEG sensors on the
forehead and then it changes the the
color and the intensity of the lights
and the one that looks like a brain is
actually one that it's like a miniature
model of a large-scale project that
we're doing with some other students and
this final example that I'm going to
show you it was inspired by my work with
the Vancouver laptop ensemble and what
it is is it's a laser heart so basically
it's a series of lasers and if you put
your hand in between one of the lasers
they'd ideally be further away I don't
have a good photo of it but you put your
hand in there and then it triggers some
code that's gonna be making music or
maybe not music but noise so I'll get to
the honest truth is that I kind of hate
the term creative coding because all
coding is creative like even if you're
not working on these kind of weird
projects every time you're faced with a
coding challenge you have to maybe think
of some sort of creative way to solve it
so for the purposes of this presentation
however I'd like to sort of define it by
two specific things one is its art space
and don't let that scare you there's
like an academic where you could look at
it and say it's about making something
that's expressive rather than a
functional product not that my laser
harp was not functional it just it was a
bit more on the expressive side so it's
art based but I prefer to think of it
more as being tech that's fun something
that's exploring a new space
something's maybe a little bit
surprising or unexpected or something
that encourages exploration and the
other way I define creative coding is
it's inclusive it's community oriented
and frankly it's how would I put this I
I had a great way of putting it but
basically because it's so built around
being doing explorations and stuff
everyone is welcome to take part in it
whether you're a professional developer
like many of you or whether you're
someone who's just getting started in
code it's more about the process than
the final product and it's more about
just having fun doing it rather than
having like the perfect code and for
that reason it's a really great activity
for people who are either brand new to
coding coming to coding from a different
field or someone who just wants to have
some fun and I would like you guys in
your mind you don't have to do this out
loud because I don't want to embarrass
you but you do not need to be an artist
to be an artist
so repeat that in your brain after me
you don't need to be an artist to be an
artist when you're making art with code
what's really awesome is that
you actually just need to tinker and
that's all you need to do to be able to
create some really fun and surprising
things a for loop in your JavaScript
program doing something else might just
iterate through some numbers but in
creative coding it could actually make a
pretty picture know the examples that I
showed you earlier we're mostly hardware
based and I did that for a reason I
showed you hardware based things because
I thought it would be really easy to
comprehend how they were kind of weird
like kind of to be honest useless sort
of examples they're cool but like
they're not they're not saving anyone's
life but you can do it with anything you
don't need to have hardware you can you
are all already JavaScript developers so
you can make interactive art in the
browser yourself you don't need to use
mspaint you can make ms paint and the
other thing that I really wanted to I
had another point on this slide but
clearly it wasn't that important so I'm
just gonna skip over I was like don't
forget that one thing and now it's the
one thing that I forgotten no it really
it wasn't that important but before you
guys go bursting out the door and
starting to work with the SVG and the
canvas elements which are really core to
doing creative interactive art in the
browser I just like to point out that
they're not always the most intuitive to
use um so I think it was actually just
pointed out in the
presentation by Shannon that if you want
to do what's up with WebGL which is
based in the html5 canvas you know it's
a lot of kind of crazy code that you've
got to go through and it's not always
super easy particularly if you're
someone who's brand new to coding or if
you're someone who's just doing it for
fun like no one wants to spend their
weekend working on a project and like
having to figure out all this like kind
of code that's really convoluted
especially since other people have
already made libraries and api's and
extensions and such that it's gonna make
it a lot easier to do this sort of stuff
in the browser so some of the libraries
that you might be familiar with are
d3.js which is a really awesome package
for working to do data visualizations
using SVG s another one that got
mentioned in the last presentation is
3GS which is great for doing like 3d
rendering in the browser but for me
personally I really love p5.js
and so you might ask why I love p5.js
because it was specifically made to
create art in the browser and so the way
it works is it makes it easy to work
with the canvas element it provides
shortcuts etc that make it really fast
and quick to create interactive data
visualizations games etc so these are
some still some screenshots from a
project that I did over the summer
they're all animated and interactive but
I didn't have time to turn them all into
gifts for you so my apologies but you
can see kind of like some of the pretty
things that you can make in the browser
and so some of you have already like I
had you guys raise your hand and see who
had already who DS processing so p5 is
actually based on processing so
processing is an IDE it's based in Java
and it's been around for almost two
decades now so it's been around for a
while and it is sort of like the go-to
standard when it comes to creative
coding if you do a google search of
creative coding you'll come up with
processing and it was really designed
for artists and non coders to be able to
create visualizations super fast and
easy without having to learn a lot of
like code that wouldn't be helpful
within that project and the neat thing
about processing is that not
only is it easy for beginners to learn
it also it's robust enough for
professional media artists for
professional developers and for
professional inventors so I just grabbed
a few stills off of their website if
some of like Processing's like gallery
in terms of like what you can do with
that so this is a data visualization
this is some really cool generated
scenes that have been printed out using
ballpoint pens with CNC machines and p5
brings this technology and the core
ideas of processing to the web so a few
years ago Lauren McCarthy worked with
the processing foundation to not only
bring over the syntax of processing but
also to bring over sort of the ethos and
by that I mean the it's a very inclusive
organization and so p5 aims to replicate
that
so processing talks about how their game
aim is to promote software literacy
visual literacy and make these fields
accessible and they do a really great
job through excellent documentation and
a fabulous YouTube channel called the
coding train with Daniel Shipman which
has like the funniest videos I think on
how to do computer science contest
concepts from beginning to much more
advanced in a really fun and accessible
way but for me what's really meaningful
and one thing that I hope that you guys
will take away from this talk if nothing
else is that if you are involved with an
open-source organization p5 has a really
obvious welcome welcoming statement a
community statement on their main page
and in that it basically says everyone
is welcome here and this might seem like
just a little bit of text on a website
that no one's ever gonna pay attention
to you but it's something that you
actually see referred to in the
community quite often so for example
we've got some screenshots here of
people who are standing in front of
presentations that have it up and also
it's reflected in the discourse forums
as well as the github pages and for me
this is really personal because I saw
that statement like I'm not necessarily
I'm not from a computer science
background I saw
statement and two days later I made my
first open-source pull request never
done it never considered it but I saw
that and I was like oh this can be my
community as a result of that I actually
applied for and successfully got a
google Summer of Code position working
with the processing foundation so these
words have meaning anyways you're gonna
race ahead do some demos show you how it
works so the way that I'm gonna go
through this is first I'm going to show
you some just how to work with the raw
canvas element without having p5 just
for comparison's sake next I'm gonna
show you how to make a p5 sketch that's
a they're word for a p5 program I'm
gonna show you a little bit about
working with externals and interactivity
and then I'm gonna show you a little bit
about plugging in like extra JavaScript
libraries oh wow you don't need to know
that yet okay so just for the interest
of time I've already like I'm not gonna
code this part live for you but when you
work with the canvas element has have
people here worked with the canvas a lot
show of hands so a lot of you have but
for those of you who haven't the way
that it works is when you create a
canvas element on the page you've got
basically just this like blank space and
anything that goes inside of the canvas
is actually invisible to the Dom so you
can't style it with CSS or anything you
have to do all of the styling through
JavaScript so I've got sort of a very
simple example here so first of all I
have to find my canvas element using
javascript next I've got to tell it that
I'm gonna be working in two dimensions
I'm not gonna be trying to do any sort
of WebGL or 3d stuff and then if I want
to make it turn to a different
background color then I've got to
actually create a new rectangle that's
the same size and shape as the existing
canvas and before hand I've also got to
actually give it the RGB value so if I
hit save and refresh I've got a nice
pink block and that's not too hard to do
actually that's not hard to do at all
but it starts to get a little bit
convoluted the more complex the sketch
gets so I've got an example here of how
to draw just a straight line so this is
gonna go from 50 across and 50 down to
and a hundred down and it requires four
lines of code I've got to begin the path
I've got to declare the first set of
coordinates I have to declare the second
set of coordinates and then I have to
tell it to actually draw that so when I
hit refresh here if I saved so look that
wasn't hard you could all do that you
could all follow along you you've got it
but as your sketch is more complicated
that's gonna become a bit of a nightmare
and if you are someone who's just
learning code or just wants to make
something in the end like that's gonna
be really frustrating to work with so
that's where p5 comes in on p5 makes
this a lot this process a lot easier and
a lot more intuitive so p5 so the first
thing you've got to do is download the
p5 libraries to your computer or you can
get them via NPM
you could also use their p5 web editor
if you don't want to download anything
and then what you have to do is there's
two main functions in in processing
there is the setup function and there is
the draw function we don't have to
declare the canvas inside of the body of
the HTML because that's something that
p5 is gonna take care of us for us so
I'm gonna create a canvas I'm gonna make
it the same size as the other one 500 by
500 and when I want to change the
background all I have to do is use the
syntax called background and fill in the
color that I want so that's already like
one line instead of two and it's a bit
more intuitive because you don't have to
build a whole new a whole new rectangle
so if I save that saving the wrong thing
refresh now I've got that pink square if
I want to draw the line I just have to
use the syntax of line again more
intuitive and I need to put the first
coordinate so 50/50 followed by the
second coordinates so 100 hundred and if
i refresh there we go I've got the same
line again identical but it's a
significantly less code
and because it's got the two chunks so
the setup function happens one time and
one time only the draw function happens
again and again and again and it
continuously rewrites over the canvas
it's actually going to be super easy to
start doing animations and more complex
interactivity so what's actually
happening here is if we were to look at
the p5 like core files that you're
downloading there's this for the line
specifically we have a function that's
already pre-made that basically runs
through that same code that we were
talking about earlier so begin path move
to line two and stroke so they've just
taken care of that they've abstracted it
out to make it a little bit easier for
you now if you wanted to start doing
things that were a little bit more
interactive you could add variables and
stuff you could add for loops and that
would allow you to do animations so for
example if I do let X equal zero and
then let's make this I want to have it
move by a factor of X every time the
canvas is refreshed X plus equals 30
save and refresh and we should have a
pretty cool animation going on okay it's
still pretty simple but we can also do
different shapes so if I wanted to do an
ellipse and I can also use my mouse
event so do stuff with externals really
easily I could get rid of the outline
that normally goes around an ellipse and
I could give it a some sort of fun color
so fill blue that sounds pretty fun and
if I save that now and refresh tada
I have in three lines of code basically
created my own mspaint like right here
right now
thank you so yeah that was just like a
two minute exercise I made I made a
mistake but what if we wanted to make it
a little bit more cool than that if we
doubled up on this ellipse for example
the fun thing about code as I mentioned
is that you can just sort of throw in
extra things and see what's cool so if I
try to add another fill ternt none other
ellipse to the page and then maybe I
made the color random so this is gonna
instead of giving me one value for red
it's gonna give me a different one every
single time that the frame refreshes
like all of a sudden I have this like
really satisfying and kind of beautiful
like drawing tool and again this is just
a really simple like sort of example you
could extend on this like really easily
and make some really cool interactive
art pieces four minutes left okay so I'm
gonna just jump right into another
example okay so this one I'm not gonna
have a time to walk you through the code
but basically it's using that same
ellipse but instead of using the mouse
coordinates what if I were to use my
face so that's gonna create a new more
interesting sort of interaction with the
computer so if I go p5 pose net so this
uses machine learning the machine
learning tensorflow das library Posen it
just cuts the load so right now instead
of drawing the ellipse on my mouse I've
actually got it drawing on my nose just
really satisfying and that didn't take a
ton of code I just had to use there's a
really great website called friendly
machine learning for the web it was I
think actually part of ITP which is
related to processing like it's the
school in New York but Daniel Shipman
the person I did that I showed you the
YouTube pages for it I think he's
involved with this project and so all I
had to do was add this plug-in and this
little this little thing that's gonna
loop through anybody's that are on
screen it's gonna be like oh is there a
person there if so give me the
coordinates of their nose
now okay this is still like not the
coolest thing but I actually want to use
this like pose net in a real project of
mine and so I decided to do some like
messing around with it the other day so
I want to unveil to you my 80s music
video generator which I hope it's gonna
come up yes it works okay so for the
very first time live in person is my
coded music video
[Music]
[Applause]
I walk away it gets bored and it turns
off and I don't even want to admit to
you how many times I practice that this
part of the presentation at home this is
thank you this is just using that pote
that same pose net basically the same
code I just showed you where instead of
doing a circle at the mouse I'm doing it
at my face but I'm also doing it on
other points on my body and I'm
jittering the circle that's around my
head and all my shoulders to make it
look kind of cool the reason there's
sort of ghost artifacts in the
background is because I set the
confidence level of the machine learning
tool to be really low so like it's
basically like could that is there any
possibility like out of like like is
there is like one percent possibility
that's a human so when it sees my wrist
it's like oh that's a person let me draw
a person for you you could set that
higher so you wouldn't have it but I
kind of liked that it gave that sort of
weird psychedelic look so I'm running
out of time here so I just wanted to
reiterate what I've what have we learned
today what have we covered so we talked
about creative coding and how it's art
based and inclusive at least if you ask
me you don't need to be an artist to do
it
p5 lets you bring processing
technologies to the web community
statements are awesome if you want to
get new people involved in your
community and it's super easy to get set
up and running as I demonstrated right
here I hope that you guys maybe feel
inspired to try it yourself I remember
what I forgot to tell you earlier is
that you might learn something while
you're doing it see though that was
important though is like pivotal because
you're not just sort of like missing
your own I mean you are you're messing
around you're just like playing but at
the same time you might learn how to do
a new leg use something new in
JavaScript you might learn how to use
something like pose knit learn a bit
more about machine learning or you might
become more involved with the community
and be able to learn more about
mentorship through helping out other
people through that community oriented
sort of discussion forums and such as
they have so if you do want to try it
you don't have to download anything you
can go to their web
site and check out the p5 at web editor
if you want to download the pose net
code it's on ml 5 je s org if you know
someone young or want to pretend like
you're underage and one or more I'm
doing a workshop on Saturday morning on
how to use this so send your kids and
your friends kids my way so if they
thank you and if you want to reach out
my twitter handle is Elgin sky or you
can say hello to me here or on the
channel you can tell me how offended you
were by my presentation or you can send
me your favorite gift jiff gift thank
you
[Applause]